hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new let's play of
Erie now this is a brand brand new indie
horror game made on the Unreal Engine
and I actually wanted to play it a few
days ago but I couldn't get to work and
I've only recently been able to
manipulate it into a working condition
but anyway so the download link is in
the description below if you want to
play it as always so I am very excited
because I know a lot of horror games get
played on the Unity engine and other
engines like that but not not wait what
setup baby oh hello uh mission
investigate whereabouts of missing
workers locate survivors
hey plus e to reexamine
there we go um mitigate further damage
to reactor or gain an treated plant
grounds conduct investigation you spray
paint to mark casualty locations danger
areas report findings Oliver this case
the cause of this event is unknown so
exercise extra caution in the facility
any insight you can provide as to the
cause of the incident would be
appreciated it's time to put that
education to use the town's folks are
scared so be friends disclosing anything
/ SOP be careful Jim okay that sounds
good I bet there's whole demons down
here and all that whoa Oh what's wrong
with my sacks of meat for arms this
break aunt I think so
and either way um you probably noticed
that I'm not wearing my headphones right
now um for some reason they're on the
fritz the sounds all crackly we're
coming out of them so I'm just using
earbuds plugged straight into my Yeti
which actually it's kind of convenient
but either way I'll get them fixed in
you know whenever I can because earbuds
really don't replace a 7.1 surround
sound headset that was really happy
because I know I've had that that's it
for a while but
who's a wireless headset - so I got a
spray paint can I think did I actually
pick it up I have no idea I was a baby
anyway I think I got it
I for inventory notes what inventory
hang on I gotta check something real
quick because I'm actually confused as
to I think I was sent down here or
paired something I want to see if
there's something on this table that I
was supposed to see these pictures oh
hello
whoa hey whoa I've got weird hands but
either way this side up yeah I'm not
sure also I control the volume directly
on my microphone so I can actually have
a volume thing that works
interesting
Oh God so confused
that's gonna shut this off what was that
geez was that oh boy
of course there's some bad stuff going
on in this nuclear reactor of course
okay anyway so I got bad I'm still not
sure what I'm supposed to do why would
they send a guy in alone to investigate
well let's tag this [ __ ] off anyway no
I'm
yeah that's an N for markiplier yeah
okay anyway probably wasted a lot of
spray paint I don't know if there's like
a limit or what but okay there are
apparently monsters in here which is
good alright I'll see I'll mark an M
four places I've been in and W four
places I should not go go W no one likes
anything W hey that Wade's a douche
anyway still exploring a bit
okay okay yeah I don't know how in depth
this game is either
it's apparently a lot of stuff to find
hello okay mark get up with on em man
that doesn't right well at all
okay no this is now a double you don't
come down here W don't be a wait guys oh
oh that's not good it's not good at all
I don't like this place all right
rats damn rat - that's the same ref
again what's with the baby oh boy Oh
found a cat ha oh alright anyway moving
on this looks good
nope stashed lab key in upstairs cell
escape imminent white coast la blah blah
blah cat keeps him at bay huh okay so
key an upstairs cell but a rat they can
rip apart a dead body in minutes seconds
even I'm not sure I like this place
all right oh that's good ah hello bats
so lovely I suppose I was expecting you
know with the spray paint can I
expecting a more maze like oh here we go
maybe I spoke too soon this looks no no
a more maze like what's with the baby oh
that's not a baby
this is Lobby key little Duma keys who's
crying this is not a nuclear reactor by
the way just saying that right now
there's the big oh that's not a baby
that's a cat oh that means early on in
the beginning there was a cat somewhere
okay why am I just picking up dead or
dying cats oh well this looks good I
like this hello
ah man I wish it would hold on to it a
little more
oh god I can't read it if it's just like
that all right
whatever that's a little annoying but oh
well okay here master key required they
got another
disposable remains God
pause the video if you want to read
those guys that's the only way it's
going to happen and I know the text is
small too so you can probably blow it up
to 720p just to be able to read it
door is magnetically sealed okay
all right it's definitely foggy in here
and oh look restrooms everyone knows in
horror games good things happen in the
restroom oh no no no oh no what what
what what what okay oh my god Oh No Oh
No I'm gonna run way better girl what is
he doing huh is he just oh okay
well that doesn't look so bad oh he's
eating me okay good god that came out of
nowhere I screwed up there Oh is he
coming after me is he sounds like he's
still there you need to get um Oh
okay so what did I get the key what
you're gonna pop up out of nowhere again
is he is he gonna he is I still think
that
oh man luckily I don't have time got it
oh my god I just wasn't ready for it
okay I'm outta here buddy
hi golly that was startling oh man
here's the maze-like area where I got to
get away from him
odds bet oh man oh oh crap oh crap oh
crap oh crap no no I got the note I read
it okay oh and oh god that would benefit
from like a sound or something when he
gets you dramatic music that's something
that this is missing music Oh what dot
okay he's eating me I get it
and okay there we go and he's gonna come
running down here isn't he he is isn't
he right around the corner yep
go buddy hey Ricky let's go
I'll use my spray-paint to tag you in
the face
okay where's cap I'll see you cap where
I don't see a cat is it a cat anyway
golly that really is something that this
game is missing I mean it's good so far
fun I mean that got me I really got me
so but what the thing is missing is
actually um some serious like music oh
god I can't I could be dead right now I
can't bother reading it I don't have
time what do I need eel generators a
warehouse okay okay okay
Hogan oh good golly okay you know a
monster coming out of here anyway
is that what's happening I still hear
the breathe you guys but I hope there is
hey buddy
hello friend of mine I'm gonna go this
way
Oh
it's all the goo boy that's not good
that's not good that's not good not good
that's not good that's not good oh look
a Bo's lag about Oh look about what's in
here oh I'm so great I'm so great
bargain Blair is great Bandar is great
okay I'm a fan all the notes I just dumb
message some other stuff oh man whoo boy
whoo doggy where am I
was that all a is it like oh man where
am i where am I going I don't even know
I better mark something up I've been
here candy can oh my I see now I see
what's going on here
ah that's why they needed the test
subjects that's why they needed all the
crap I got it okay that's why they had
the prisoners it's all making sense now
whoo what the hell it's kitty kitty
kitty cat kitty are you in here Pookie G
3 key aah
ooh ah that's a guy guy was lame oh
definitely dodged like adjusted ly huge
Oh get out it so I need like it I need
like a pause
I need a pause I'm out of time let me
just get an event
give me an event you mean event give me
an event that Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben Ben
Ben Ben band all right Wow he's a Leo K
I'm actually all out of time thank you
guys so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos and let me
know what you think of this in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye